- You guys are from Texas, right?
You two are from Texas, right?
- Mm-hm.
- Where are you from?
- Well I'm from Dallas, Texas
but I grew up in a small
town called Little Elm.
- Yeah!
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] I know where that's at.
I'm from Ft. Worth so,
- Oh okay, dope.
My whole side of my dad's
family's over there, so.
- That's awesome, where are you from?
- Well I'm from Dallas,
kind of Fort Worth area.
I'm from place called
Grapevine but I think,
- [Kelly] No, I know Grapevine!
- Yeah, I'm from Grapevine!
- Yeah!
- I think that my,
- I used to sing there!
I think something when, I
can't remember what it was,
but I used to sing in Grapevine.
Yeah, yeah!
- That's so cool.
I think that my grandparents though,
they live where you're from. Burr,
- Burleson!
- Burleson, yeah.
That's where my grandparents are from.
- It's Burleson, yeah. No, no.
I grew up kind of half and half.
Fort Worth and Burleson.
Yeah. Yeah.
That's so crazy, I love Texas women.
I love you too, we go back too, Isabella.
- We do! We go back.
(Kelly laughs)
So what do you miss about
Texas though out here,
I miss queso and chips.
- Oh!
- Ooh yeah.
- You know what, my momma
makes some bomb queso,
but you know.
- [Kelly] Okay well I'll get her number.
- Yes. But I mean, I love
everything about Texas really.
I kinda miss the weather though.
And you know it kinda,
- See, I kinda felt like it was
God's hairdryer in the summer.
- Yeah but like but
like my skin was clear,
my hair was all luscious.
Like you know, it was nice
over there, but I mean,
I also miss the food,
obviously like Pappadeaux's.
I mean, that's like all over the south.
- I love that you know Pappadeaux's.
- Pappadeaux's is it.
Like we just went to
Texas not too long ago
and like, that was the first place we went
was Pappadeaux's.
- [Kelly] I know, you hit your spots.
- Yes.
- Definitely. What about you?
- Oh well, I mean I
really miss my family, but
there's also the food.
- Yes, I think that's
what every Texan says.
- Yeah, I really miss, like
getting sweet tea everywhere
and queso and I miss, so specifically,
I miss CC's Pizza even though
I know that it's not the best
pizza in the world, I like their,
- I love that you just said CC's Pizza.
After church every
Sunday, when I was a kid,
we would get, no joke,
they had this dessert pizza
it had like powdered
sugar and like a choc,
and I was like,
"This is the best thing
that's ever happened to me.
And Jesus."
And yeah, but it was every Sunday
I was excited about Jesus
and that dessert pizza.
That's amazing, I love that you said that.